- Ces deux hommes ont un membre
de leur famille hospitalisé
depuis le mois de mai pour
un grave problème de santé :
Daljinder Nahar, qui a 43 ans.
Le foie de M. Nahar est
tellement en mauvais état
qu'une transplantation semble
le seul traitement possible.
Dans son dossier médical,
il est écrit que...
Pour éviter le pire, son frère,
son beau-frère et d'autres
membres de la famille se portent
volontaires pour un éventuel
don d'organe.
Vous être prêts à donner
une partie de votre foie
pour sauver votre frère?
- Absolu
- Absolument.
- Parce que vous pensez
qu'il vaut la peine
d'être sauvé.
- Absolument!
Absolument, c'est mon frère.
On va pas juste arrêter
comme ça.
- Le problème, c'est que
M. Nahar souffre d'alcoolismedel
qui a détruit son foie et
qu'il n'a jamais été sobre
durant une période prolongée.
Pour cette raison, on refuse
de lui gnouveau foie.
Me PATRICK MARTIN-MÉNARD,
avocat de la famille Nahar
- On le considère inadmissible
à une greffe en raison du fait
que sa condition est attribuable
à une consommation d'alcool
et on lui impose, en fait,
une période de sobriété de
six mois en dehors d'un milieu
hospitalde pouvoir
considérer qu'il est admissible
à une greffe de foie.
- Là, on a un problème :
il pourrait être mort, décédé
avant la fin de sa période
de sobriété?
- Exactement.
- Depuis trois mois, M. Nahar,
qui est traité au centrehospitaé
plusieurs refus, d'abord auprès
du CUSM. On peut lire dans
son dossier...
Son dossier a ensuite
été présenté à cinq centres
de transplantation au Canada.
Même résultat : non admissible.
KIRANPAL NAHAR,
frère de Daljinder Nahar
- Nous aussi, on a contacté
nous-mêcontacté
des centres de transplantation
partout au Canada, Alberta,
Ontario : ils ont dit
la même chose.
- C'est-à-dire?
- Il faut attendre six mois,
il faut être sous contrôle,
même si son état est grave,
rendu à la fin, ils disent non.
- L'avocat de la famille Nahar
croit que cette approche
médicale est trop stricte,
qu'on juge son client uniquement
sur son comportement passé.
- C'est un critère qui est
discriminatoire à sa face même.c
d'autres éléments qui ne sont
pas pris en compte, par exemple
une personne qui aurait fait des
choix alimentaireséééééé
à la perte de son foie va être
admissible à une greffe de foie.
- Cette Torontoise
avis. Son mari, alcoolique, est
mort en 2010 après s'être fait
refuser une greffe d'un donneur
vivant. Elle conteste maintenant
la règle devant lux.
Mais pour la famille Nahar,
le temps file. Sans greffe
du foie, ils vont probablement
perdre leur frère., beau-frère
de Daljinder Nahar
- Nous sommes conscients que
ça peut pas même réussir, OK.
Il y a d'autres choses
qui peuvent être.s
problèmes qui peuvent venir,
on sait pas... OK?
Mais la chose qui est difficile,
c'est qu'aucune peluiluiluiluili
donne même la chance pour être
considéré comme un candidat.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.